>>> ANYBODY REMEMBER THE GIPPER?
THIS IS HOW PRESIDENT RONALD
REAGAN STOOD UP TO THE SOVIETS
IN1987.
>> MR. GORBACHEV, TEAR DOWN THIS
WALL.
>> RONALD REAGAN STARED DOWN THE
KREMLIN AND WIDELY CREDITED WITH
WINNING THE COLD WAR AGAINST THE
SOVIETS.
AND NOW, THERE IS MUCH DIFFERENT
REACTIONS OF WHAT WAS ONCE THE
PARTY OF THE GOP, AND THE
POTENTIAL ENTRY INTO UKRAINE AND
THEIR ENTRY INTO NATO.
AND WHAT WOULD JUSTIFY OUR GOING
INTO WAR OVER UKRAINE'S FATE.
AND NATO AND BOTH PARTIES ARE
SAYING THAT WE SHOULD RESPECT
UKRAINE'S FATE, BUT NOW, IT
SESEEM
S THAT TUCKER CARLSON AND
CONGRESSMAN HOLLY IS LOOKING TO
SIDE WITH UKRAINE.
>> WHY ARE WE SIDING WITH
UKRAINE WHICH IS STRANGE.
>> AND THAT IS WHY ADAM
KINZINGER LAID INTO HOLLY.
>> I HATE TO BE SO PERSONAL,
BECAUSE HOLLY IS SO
AGGRANDIZING, AND HOLLY AND
TUCKER CARLSON ARE FORMING A
SORT OF REAGANISM AFTER PUTTING
ONE OF THE FIRST WOMEN ON THE
COURT SANDRA DAY O'CONNOR.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK THAT STACEY
ABRAMS CAN SAVE US?
OUT OF HER ROLE COMPLETELY.
I AM SORRY IF THAT PAINTS ME AS
A SEXIST PIG, BUT IT IS WHAT I
BELIEVE.
>> WELL, THAT IS JUST AN EP ITEH
DESIGNED TO MAKE YOU BE QUIET,
BUT WHY ARE YOU NOT ALLOWED TO
HAVE THAT OPINION, BECAUSE IT IS
THE OPINION OF EVERY SOCIETY
UNTIL ABOUT 20 MINUTES.
>> AND NO PUSHBACK FROM CARLSON,
AND IS CARLSON ALSO A SEXIST
PIG, AND AS HE WOULD SAY, I
DON'T KNOW, I AM JUST ASKING A
QUESTION, AND WHY AREN'T YOU
ALLOWED TO HAVE THAT OPINION.
AND REAGAN BELIEVED IN A BIG
TENT GOP, AND APPOINTED COLIN
POWELL AS THE FIRST SECRETARY OF
STATE.
CONSIDER HOW TUCKER ECHOED
REAGAN'S STATEMENTS OF HAITI AND
BALT
BALTIMORE, AND HE REFERRED TO
HAITI AS A SHITHOLE, AND HE SAID
THAT BALTIMORE IS WHEN YOU APPLY
JEN PSAKI'S IDEA TO GOVERNING.
>> BUT IT IS CLEAR THAT THE GOP
WILL NOT STAND UP TO TISHG OR
TRUMP IN A FIT OF ORWELLIAN
TRUMPISM, THEY WILL NOW CALLING
ON CALLING TO INVESTIGATE NANCY
PELOSI FOR DOING SUCH A POOR JOB
OF OVERSEEING SECURITY AND ALSO
MIKE PENCE FOR HIS PART OF
SAYING WHAT NEEDED TO BE SAID.
>> I HEARD THIS WEEK THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID THAT I HAD
THE RIGHT TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WRONG.
>> NOW, PENCE'S MOMENTARY ACT OF
COURAGE ASIDE, THE GOP IS NOW
REWARDING TRUMP FOR HIS LIES.
>> IT IS HIS PARTY, AND NOT
DESANTIS' PARTY OR LINDSEY
GRAHAM'S PARTY, AND HE IS GOING
TO BE THE NOMINEE IN 2024 IF HE
WANTS IT.
STAY TUNED.
>> CASE IN POINT, WHEN SENATOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM DISAGREED WITH
THE IDEA OF PARDONNING JANUARY
6th INSURRECTIONISTS HE WAS
SMACKED DOWN.
>> LINDSEY GRAHAM IS WRONG.
AND I WOULD BE PREPARED AND
LINDSEY GRAHAM DOES NOT KNOW
WHAT THE HELL IS HE TALKING
ABOUT.
>> IT IS BECAUSE THE REPUBLICAN
LEADERS WON'T TAKE THE TRASH OUT
IN THEIR PARTY, IT KEEPS PILING
UP.
THERE WAS A BOOK BURNING IN
TENNESSEE ONE WEEK AFTER A BOOK
OF THE HOLOCAUST WAS BANNED IN A
SEPARATE PART OF THE STATE.
THE GOP SILENT FROM THE
REPUBLICAN LEADERS.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SPINE TO
CONFRONT MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE.
>> I THINK THAT PEOPLE HAVE
BLOOD ON THEIR HANDS FOR THE
STOPPING OF PRESCRIPTIONS OF
I
IVERMECTIN, AND IT IS BECAUSE OF
DR. FAUCI OR ANYONE AT THE CDC
THAT STOPPED LIFE-SAVING
THERAPIES AND PEOPLE DIED AND
THEY ARE GUILTY OF MURDER.
>> WHAT IS LEFT OF RONALD
REAGAN'S PARTY?
SENATOR TED CRUZ THIS IT IS FUN
TO SEND OUT TIPS FOR RIDING OUT
A WINTER STORM, AND SAYING THAT
PLANE TICKETS TO CANCUN IS UP
32%.
HE COULD EVOKE WINSTON CHURCHILL
AND SAY, KEEP CALM AND CARRY ON,
AND PEOPLE MIGHT ASK, FIRST
CLASS OR COACH.
AND THIS SEASON THE "MASKED
SINGER" IS THE GOOD, THE BAD,
AND THE CUDDLY.
AND PERHAPS HE COULD DO SHAGGY'S
HIT "IT WASN'T ME."
DID YOU INCITE A RIOT?
IT WASN'T ME.
WERE YOU CAUGHT AT FOUR SEASONS?
AND SADLY FOR THE MAN ONCE
DUBBED AMERICA'S MAYOR, IT WAS
THE SARAH PALIN, IT WASN'T ME.
AND THEN THE GOP CENSURING TWO
OF ITS OWN, AND THE RNC
RESOLUTION DESCRIBES ATTACK ON
THE CAPITOL AS LEGITIMATE
DISCOURSE, AND THERE WAS NOTHING
LEGITIMATE ABOUT IT.
THIS IS WAY WORSE THAN THE 11th
COMMANDMENT, THOU SHALL NOT
SPEAK ILL OF A FELLOW
REPUBLICAN.
AND NOW IF ONE OF THE PARTIES IS
EMBRACING THIS AS LEGITIMATE
DISCOURSE, WE OWE IT TO ONE
ANOTHER TO TELL THE TRUTH.
THIS IS A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS NOW
BECOME A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
THE PARTY HAS CHOSEN THE COURSE.
IT IS